[Musique]
amoureux des animaux et des produits
fermiers le rendez-vous des juniors et
pour vous mélanie cette semaine on se
rend dans une ferme à la fin de grignon
tous pris de plaisir à leurs sentiments
c'est le rendez vous annuel leur journée
portes ouvertes
huit heures sans interruption pour
découvrir les coulisses de
l'exploitation mais pas seulement
les équipes de la ferme ont prévu un
programme complet démonstration de
chiens de troupeaux des balades en poney
des balades en tracteur est même l'un
pirates de paille difficile de tout
citer c'est aussi l'intérêt de pouvoir
expliquer au public aux portes de deux
de ses grandes agglomérations qu'on en
ile de france il ya encore des
agriculteurs et nous notamment acquis
sommes ouverts et les gourmands ne sont
pas oubliés alors il ya aussi un marché
de producteurs avec 17 exposants de
produits traditionnels locaux la ferme
présentera aussi des produits issus des
lycées agricoles qu'elles vont en temps
normal dans sa boutique gourmaud et pour
cette journée portes ouvertes l'entrée
est libre
il n'y a pas d'inscription il n'y a que
la météo pour empêcher d'en profiter ce
week-end c'est un peu le week-end qui
fait me la vache salers et restaurants
oui oui du côté de la bergerie nationale
on s'intéresse à la vache entre
tradition et modernité
là aussi des animations sont prévues
pour les plus jeunes vous pourrez
déjeuner et goûter autour des produits
laitiers dont une assiette de fromages
qui a été concocté par ludovic bizot
c'est un fromage et il est aussi
meilleur ouvrier de france 2015 alors
difficile là aussi de tout citer la
programmation étant riche mais samedi et
dimanche il y aura de quoi donner envie
de devenir un vrai petit fermier
merci mélanie le rendez vous est donc
pris pour se régaler et on apprendre
plus sur les métiers de l'agriculture